Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Vamos a hacer
un experimento multitudinario.
A las personas que
están en el Teatro Colón
les cuento que llegó el momento
de que abran sus sobres.
Vamos a discutir un crimen,
discutir un asesinato,
que involucra un incidente
automovilístico.
En una pequeña ciudad de
la Provincia de Buenos Aires
fue hallado un cuerpo
al costado de la ruta.
La víctima fue atropellada y abandonada
entre la noche del sábado
y la madrugada del domingo.
La persona responsable se dio a la fuga
y no asistió a la víctima.
Hay tres personas sospechosas
de haber cometido el crimen,
pero la policía no tiene evidencia
suficiente como para detener a alguien.
Este trágico incidente
ya hizo eco en toda la ciudad
y los vecinos empezaron a circular
información como por ejemplo...
Y ahí van a encontrar frases que
son declaraciones, testimonios,
de esos vecinos acerca de las tres
personas sospechosas de esta historia.
Dani, Gabi y Agus.
Tienen que leer atentamente la información
y decidir de manera individual
qué persona les parece
que es más sospechosa: Dani, Gabi o Agus.
Y, además, les pedimos por favor,
que nos indiquen qué tan seguros
están de esa decisión
en una escala que va
entre poco y muy seguros.
A partir de este momento tienen un minuto
y medio para hacer eso. Adelante.
Muy bien. Se nos terminó el tiempo.
Y con esto terminó
la primera parte del experimento.
Vamos rápidamente a ver qué vamos a hacer
en la segunda y última
parte del experimento.
Ahora ya no vamos a tomar decisiones
a nivel individual,
sino que vamos a trabajar
en grupos de tres.
Pero los grupos no van a ser cualquiera.
Yo les voy a decir cómo van a encontrarse.
Lo primero que tienen que hacer
es encontrar a dos personas
que están sentadas muy cerca de Uds.
y tienen el mismo número de participante.
Por el momento solamente encuéntrense.
Y cuando se encuentren,
por favor, levanten sus papeles.
Muchas gracias,
ya pueden bajar los papeles.
Tienen que hacer dos cosas nada más.
Número uno: van a discutir
durante cinco minutos
y llegar a una conclusión consensuada,
una conclusión colectiva,
acerca de qué persona
les pareció más sospechosa.
Y luego tienen que decirnos además
qué tan de acuerdo están
con esa decisión grupal.
¿Vieron que a veces cuando uno
es parte de un equipo
siente que está de acuerdo
con lo que se discutió
y a veces siente que
no está tan de acuerdo?
Bueno, les pedimos por favor,
que nos indiquen
qué tan de acuerdo
están a nivel individual
en una escala que va entre poco
y muy de acuerdo.
A partir de este momento tienen
cinco minutos para discutir.
Adelante.
Se terminó el tiempo para discutir.
A las personas que ya llegaron
a una conclusión,
les recuerdo que con esto
se nos terminó el experimento.
(Aplausos)
Antes de terminar, antes de irme,
quisiera compartir con Uds.
algunas de las ideas e hipótesis
que teníamos en este experimento.
Primero hay que notar que les pedí
que identificaran
qué persona les parecía más sospechosa
entre tres perfiles.
Y que cada uno de los perfiles
tenía información positiva
más bien exonerante,
como "Si toma alcohol no maneja"
y también tenían información
negativa como, por ejemplo,
"Tiene la cédula verde vencida".
Si bien los tres perfiles tenían
información positiva y negativa,
había uno de ellos que tenía
más información incriminante
y era para todos los grupos
la misma persona:
¿Adivinan quién es esa persona que
tenía más información incriminante?
Por favor, díganlo.
La persona con más información
incriminante era Dani.
Ahora bien, en este momento yo ya sé
que más o menos la mitad
de este auditorio no me cree mucho.
Y no me cree mucho porque
para darse cuenta de que Dani
era la persona con
más información incriminante
tenían no solamente
que trabajar en equipo
sino darse cuenta de que
tenían frases repetidas
y frases que no eran repetidas
y si ponían toda junta la información,
bueno ahí uno se podía
dar cuenta de que Dani
era la persona con
más información incriminante.
Con esto no quiero decir que Dani
es la respuesta correcta.
Yo les pregunté una opinión.
Una decisión que en definitiva
es subjetiva.
Y Uds. podrían tener muy buenos argumentos
para decir que para Uds. la persona
más sospechosa es Gabi o Agus.
Pero lo que uno no querría
es que esa decisión,
por más subjetiva que sea,
esté influenciada
o sesgada por cómo accedieron
a la información.
O cómo la información estuvo
distribuida dentro del grupo.
Por eso teníamos dos condiciones
experimentales.
Grupos del 1 al 500 tenían
información completa.
Es decir, podían ver toda la información
de todos los perfiles antes de decidir.
Los grupos del 501 al 1000
tenían la información distribuida.
Eso en esencia quiere decir
que solo veían seis frases por perfil,
parte de esa información era compartida,
parte no era compartida,
y tenían la tarea difícil
de darse cuenta de que Dani
era la persona más incriminante.
Estas son mis ideas pero,
más allá de las ideas,
¿quieren que intentemos ver
los resultados?
Público: Sí.
Levanten la mano de los grupos
1 al 500 los que eligieron a Dani.
Solo los que eligieron a Dani.
Bueno, vemos una mayoría bastante grande.
Ahora, de los grupos 501 al 1000,
levanten la mano
los que eligieron a Dani.
Bastante menos.
Bueno, creemos --y lo acaban
de vivir en primera persona--
y es algo que nos pasa
a los seres humanos,
es el sesgo de información compartida.
Es una tendencia que tenemos a discutir
aquello que tenemos en común
por sobre las cosas distribuidas,
las cosas únicas que tenemos,
que paradójicamente pueden ser aquellas
que nos hagan trabajar mejor como equipo.
¿Saben cuál es el correlato cultural
de este sesgo?
¿Qué es lo que pasa en la sociedad
que se parece a esto?
Es la influencia que tienen los medios
de comunicación sobre nuestra sociedad.
Pensémoslo.
Si nos interesa discutir aquello
que tenemos en común, bueno,
vamos a darle mucha importancia a aquello
que está en la radio, en la tele,
en los diarios, y también obviamente
en las redes sociales,
porque es aquello que justamente
tenemos en común.
Pero si eso es así, eso nos deja también
en una posición de vulnerabilidad
cuando de golpe nos enteramos de
que la información que consumimos
podría llegar a ser falsa.
Como por ejemplo en el caso
de las noticias falsas.
Por eso es que además
la información estaba dividida
--los papeles que tenían estaban divididos
en otras dos condiciones experimentales--
que son grupos con información verificada
a los cuales les decíamos en un cartel
que la información había sido chequeada
y que no había información falsa
y a la mitad le dijimos lo opuesto.
Les dijimos que la información
no había sido verificada
y, justamente, que podría haber
información falsa.
Estamos tratando de ver cómo
la gente discute la información,
cómo integra información cuando duda
de la veracidad de esa misma.
Esto no lo sabemos.
Justamente son hipótesis.
Y para eso les pedimos que
por favor en este momento
guarden los papeles de nuevo en los sobres
y a la salida del teatro que
se lo entreguen a los voluntarios
que los van a estar esperando
con mucha ansiedad, van a ver.
Por último, quisiera concluir
que esos papeles
justamente nos pueden llevar a entender
por qué concientizar
a la gente acerca, por ejemplo,
del problema de las noticias falsas,
puede llegar a dar lugar
a mejores debates democráticos.
Muchas, muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)